if there's anything that can warm me up
during this cold canadian winter it's
definitely a movie about a giant armored
vehicle
plunging into a frozen lake below zero
netflix's latest spanish film since the
platform
isn't a movie about my score on
hotternot.com but an
action-packed adventure through spain's
frigid rural side roads because when
you're transferring a group of convicted
felons you always take the creepy
backroads but before we begin
warm my frigid heart by clicking that
like and subscribe button so i can come
out with more videos that disappoint my
parents below zero doesn't pull
any punches
okay some punches this is the opening
scene where a hooded figure beats the
crap
out of a man named chino remember him
because he'll be important
later on meet martin our film's
protagonist it's his first day on the
job and he's assigned with transferring
a group of felons to a prison up north
what we'll learn about martin is that
he's a rule follower he believes in the
law and treating the prisoners with
respect
naturally he's partnered with a man who
bends the rules treats the prisoners
like [ __ ] and
isn't afraid to beat them up this is all
part of martin's character arc for
discretion
and security purposes that transfer is
done at night and done
through the back roads the prisoners
aren't told they're being moved and the
police aren't allowed to carry cell
phones
to make matters worse one of the
prisoners they're transferring is a
romanian crime boss
the ringleader of an international crime
syndicate along with him are other
prisoners ramis a bank robber who stole
money to support his dream of opening up
a restaurant in the caribbean
ray a man who put his sister's assaulter
in a coma in his serving nine years
hardo also known as the economist who
scammed people out of millions
nano i forgot what he's in there for
probably for being named after an ipod
and gollum yep his name is gollum the
trek north begins with a patrol car
escorting the truck but as a mysterious
fog makes visibility almost non-existent
martin soon loses visual at the same
time remiss has a trick up his sleeve or
should i say
butt because he's shoved a hook up there
which he'll later use to escape his cell
jesus what's up his butt [ __ ] really
hits the fan when the hooded figure from
the beginning
lays a group of spikes halting the truck
whoever did this
knew this transfer was coming and was
prepared montecinos goes out to
investigate but after martin loses
communication with him over the radio he
goes out too
finding his badly injured partner but he
can't do anything because he's
immediately shot at and runs into the
forest where he finds that patrol car
and its two officers
dead with nowhere left to run he locks
himself back in the truck
trapped with the murderous prisoners and
if things couldn't get any worse the
hooded figure starts pouring gasoline in
the truck
forcing martin to let the other
prisoners out the wall street guy is
burnt to death that's what you get for
trying to short gamestop
everyone suspects that the person
wanting into this truck is somehow
linked to the romanian but when the
hooded man
communicates over the radio we learn
that's not the case
in fact the mysterious man who calls
himself miguel
will let them all free in exchange for
nano
everyone is like hey that sounds like a
good idea but before
anyone can do anything nano completely
out of the blue
kills the romanian with a fire
extinguisher steals the key from him and
swallows it
very tasty basically he makes it so that
no one can get in and no one can get
out so the prisoners are in a dilemma
miguel wants nano alive so they can't
rip him open to get the key out and they
don't have enough time to wait for him
to
pass it because the heat's been disabled
they could freeze to death martin is
locked up while the guys look for a
different way out
underneath the truck's floorboard while
this is happening miguel takes control
of the truck and drives away when we
learn that montecino is still
alive he calls for help and takes
miguel's truck to chase after them
where he finds pictures of a young girl
and a newspaper clipping that says
police resume search for the body of
soul dad garcia so miguel
obviously has something to do with this
young girl montecino catches up to the
truck and tries doing his best mad max
but ends up crashing into a tree
miguel slams the break which causes rey
who was underneath the floorboards
trying to escape at the time to be
impaled on a screw
so miguel is like i can't get these guys
out they can't get themselves out and i
could get caught so let's set this truck
in the middle of a frozen lake
and to make sure no one gets away he'll
shoot around the ice so the truck falls
to the icy bottom
and the guys inside aren't too keen on
this idea
martin says there's actually a secret
exit to the truck
way to bring that up now martin it's
located above the fluorescent light
along the roof meanwhile
nano is like i screw you guys i'm going
home
and ramis helps martin undo his cuffs
and they barely make it out alive now
miguel thinking he's killed everyone
notices that nano made it out so he goes
on one final hunt which is the last act
of the film and when remiss and martin
get out we start to see how martin's
character arc
is changing remiss asks him what now is
martin going to let him free
remiss could have left him chained up
down there but risked his own life to
save him
so martin lets him go asking him what
he's going to call his restaurant he's
dreamed about opening martin has always
been a rule follower so we start to see
here how he's beginning to change
martin hears gunshots and rushes towards
them at this point he's trying to stop
miguel from killing nano but we still
don't really know why miguel is going
through
all these lengths to get at him that is
until martin catches up
and we hear miguel's full story remember
those pictures in that newspaper article
montecino found in miguel's car
well that was miguel's 13 year old
daughter nano and his friend chino the
guy from the beginning of the movie
drugged and raped her tying her to their
car and dragging her through a field
an investigation found insufficient
evidence to implicate nano and chino so
they got off scot-free
that's why miguel has a disdain for the
law and takes matters into his
own hands he wants revenge but more
importantly to find out where nano
disposed of his daughter's body there's
a part of martin that still holds on to
the law
he knows he can't let miguel go through
with this
the two end up fighting with miguel
escaping but martin is able to grab his
gun he quickly chases after him to find
miguel
on top of nano and holds the two at
gunpoint up until now
nano has proclaimed his innocence he
says he doesn't know anything about
miguel's daughter but as a police
helicopter descends and it looks like
miguel is going to be caught
nano gleefully reveals
this is where martin has to make a
choice he can wait for backup to arrive
and let the law play out or he can take
matters into his own hands and do what's
right
but that would mean breaking the law
martin points the gun at nano and
demands he tell miguel where his
daughter is buried and when nano refuses
he blows his hand off this is something
the martin at the beginning of the film
never would have done now getting your
hand blown off totally sucks and when
you're confronted with a cop who's
willing to go this far
you better give up that info and that's
what nano does
giving them her location and telling
them she was dropped down a well miguel
will undoubtedly go to jail for what he
did but at least he can now rest easy
knowing his daughter can be put to rest
martin is another story he clears out
his locker likely having been fired for
what he did
but there's a moment where he looks at a
picture of his daughters there's a small
part of him that understands the pain
and lengths a father will go
to protect his children but this ending
thematically ties into one of the first
scenes of the film martin has to fix a
flat tire and his daughter asks him
what happens with the old one martin
replies
martin is the old tire in this story
he's tossed away at the end but what
matters is that he did the right thing
of course that's just my interpretation
what did you think of below zero
i want to hear your thoughts and
comments below thanks for watching
everyone let me know what you thought
about this more recap style of a video
please make sure to like and subscribe
and for more bad takes you can always
follow me on twitter and instagram
kingstoryyt until next time remember
daddy loves you very much